What Are You Afraid Of?
Cowards die many times before their deaths.
The valiant never taste of death but once.
Of all the wonders that I yet have heard,...
...It seems to me most strange that men should fear;...
...Seeing that death, a necessary end,...
...Will come when it will come.
In Julius Caesar (1599) written by William Shakespeare...
"People living deeply have no fear of death."  - Anais Nin
"Only when we are no longer afraid do we begin to live." - Dorothy Thompson
"Don't be afraid to go out on a limb. That's where the fruit is." - H. Jackson Browne
"Too many people are thinking of security instead of opportunity." - James F. Bymes
"Nothing in life is to be feared. It is only to be understood." - Marie Curie
"Ultimately we know deeply that the other side of every fear is a freedom." - Marilyn Ferguson
"You can judge your age by the amount of pain you feel...
... when you come in contact with a new idea. - Pearl S. Buck
"Worry gives a small thing a big shadow." - Swedish Proverb